The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK.
Now, clustering for graphs.
So this is a topic--
this is one of the
important things
you can try to do with a graph.
So you have a large graph.
Let me kind of divide
it into two clusters.
So you've got a giant graph.
And then the job is to
make some sense out of it.
And one possible step is
to be able to subdivide it,
if, as I see here, there's
a cut between two reasonably
equal parts of the graph--
reasonable--
reasonably same size.
And therefore, that graph
could be studied in two pieces.
So the question is, how do you
find such a cut by a algorithm?
What's an algorithm that
would find that cut?
So that's a problem.
Let's say we're looking
for two clusters.
We could look for more
clusters, but let's say we
want to look for two clusters.
So what are we trying to do?
We're trying to minimize.
So this is the problem, then.
So we look for--
find positions x
and y, let's say.
Two which will be the
centers, so to speak, of the--
and really, it's just
these points that--
so the data is the
points and the edges,
as always-- the
nodes and the edges.
So the problem is to
find x and y so that--
to minimize.
So it's a distance
of points ai from x--
maybe should emphasize
we're in high dimensions--
plus the distance
of other points.
So the ai will be these points--
these nodes.
And the bi will be these
nodes, plus the sum
of bi minus y squared.
And you understand
the rule here--
that together the a's union
the b's give me all nodes.
And I guess to be complete, the
a's intersect the b's is empty.
Just what you expect.
I'm dividing the a's and
the b's into two groups.
And I'm picking
an x and a y sort
of at the center of those
groups, so that is a minimum.
So I want to minimize.
And also, I probably want to
impose some condition that
the number of a's is reasonably
close to the number of b's.
In other words, I don't want
just that to be the a, and all
the rest to be the b's.
That would be not a
satisfactory clustering.
I'm looking for clusters
that are good sized clusters.
So minimize that.
OK.
So there are a lot of
different algorithms to do it.
Some are more directly
attacking this problem.
Others use matrices that we
associate with the graph.
So let me tell you about two
or three of those algorithms.
And if you've seen--
studied-- had a course
in graph theory, this--
you may already have
seen this problem.
First question would be,
suppose I decide these are
the a's, and those are the
b's-- or some other decision.
Yeah, probably some
other decision.
I don't want to solve the
problem before I even start.
So some a's and some b's.
What would be the best choice
of the x once you've decided
on the a's?
And what would be the
best choice of the y once
you've decided on the b's?
So we can answer that question
if we knew the two groups.
We could see where they
should be centered,
with the first group centered
at x, the second group centered
at y, and what does
centering mean?
So let's just say--
so I think what I'm
saying here is--
let me bring that down a little.
So given the a's--
the a's-- this is
a1 up to, say, ak.
What is the best x just
to make that part right?
And the answer is, to do
you know, geometrically,
what x should be here?
X is the-- so if I
have a bunch of points,
and I'm looking for the
middle of those points--
the point x-- a good point x
to say, OK, that's the middle.
It'll make the sum of the
distances, I think, squared--
I hope I'm right about that--
a minimum.
What is x?
It is the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG: Centroid.
Centroid is the word.
X is the centroid of the a's.
And what is the centroid?
Let's see.
Oh, maybe I don't know if
x and y were a good choice,
but let me see what--
I guess, it's the average a.
It's the sum of the a's--
of these a's.
Those are vectors, of course,
divided by the number of a's.
I think.
Actually, I was just quickly
reviewing this morning,
so I'm not totally on
top of this centroid.
What I'm going to talk--
the algorithm that I'm going
to talk about is the k--
well, the k-means,
it's always called.
And here it will be
the-- k will be 2.
I just have two--
partitioning into two sets,
a's and b's, so I just-- k
is just 2.
OK.
What's the algorithm?
Well, if I've
chosen a partition--
the a's and b's have
separated them--
then that tells me what
the x and the y should be.
But, now what do I do next?
So is this going to be a sort
of an alternating partition?
Now I take those two centroids.
So step one is for
given a's and b's, find
the centroids x and y.
And that's elementary.
Then the second step is,
given the centroids, x and y--
given those positions--
given x and y--
they won't be centroids
when you see what happened.
Given x and y, redo--
form the best partition--
best clusters.
So step one, we had a guess at
what the best clusters were.
And we found they're centroids.
Now, we start with
the centroids,
and we form new clusters again.
And if these clusters
are the same as the ones
we started with, then the
algorithm is converged.
But probably they won't be--
these clusters.
So you'll have to tell me what
I mean by the best clusters.
If I've got the two points,
x and y, I want the points--
I want to separate
all the points
that cluster around x to the
ones that cluster around y.
And then, they're
probably different
from my original start.
So now I've got new--
now I repeat step one.
But let's just think, how
do I form the best clusters?
Well, I take a point and I have
to decide, does it go with x,
or does it go within
the x cluster,
or does it go in the
cluster around y?
So how do I decide that?
Just whichever one
it's closer to.
So each point goes
with each node.
You should-- I
could say, each node
goes with the closer of x and y.
So points that
should have been--
that are closer to x-- now
we're going to put them
in the cluster around x.
And does that solve the problem?
No, because-- well, it
might, but it might not.
We'd have to come
back to step one.
We've now changed the clusters.
They'll have
different centroids.
So we repeat step one--
find the centroids
for the two new clusters.
Then we come to step two.
Find the ones that should
go with the two centroids,
and back and forth.
I don't know.
I don't think there's a
nice theory of convergence,
or rate of convergence--
all the questions
that this course
is always asking.
But it's a very popular
algorithm, k-means.
k would be to have k clusters.
OK.
So that's a--
I'm not going to discuss the--
I'd rather discuss some
other ways to do this,
to solve this problem.
But that's one sort of
hack that works quite well.
OK.
So second approach is
what is coming next.
Second solution
method-- and it's
called the spectral clustering.
That's the name of the method.
And before I write down what
you do, what does the word
spectral mean?
You see spectral graph
theory, spectral clustering.
And in other parts of
mathematics, you see that--
you see spectral theorem.
I gave you the most--
and I described it as the
most important-- perhaps--
theorem in linear algebra--
at least one of the top three.
So I'll write it over
here, because it's not--
it doesn't-- this is--
it's the same word, spectral.
Well, let me ask
that question again?
What's that word spectral about?
What does that mean?
That means that if
I have a matrix,
and I want to talk
about its spectrum, what
is the spectrum of the matrix?
It is the eigenvalues.
So spectral theory,
spectral clustering
is using the eigenvalues
of some matrix.
That's what that
spectral is telling me.
Yeah.
So the spectral
theorem, of course,
is that for a symmetric matrix
S, the eigenvalues are real,
and the eigenvectors
are orthogonal.
And don't forget what the
real, full statement is here,
because there could be
repeated real eigenvalues.
And what does the
spectral theorem tell me
for symmetric matrices,
if lambda equals
5 is repeated four times--
if it's a four times
solution of the equation that
gives eigenvalues, then
what's the conclusion?
Then there are four independent,
orthogonal eigenvectors
to go with it.
We can't say that
about matrices--
about all matrices.
But we can say it about
all symmetric matrices.
And in fact, those
eigenvectors are orthogonal.
So we're even saying more.
We can find four
orthogonal eigenvectors
that go with a multiplicity
for eigenvalues.
OK.
That's spectral theorem.
Spectral clustering starts with
the graph Laplacian matrix.
May I remember what
that matrix is?
Because that's the key
connection of linear algebra
to graph theory, is the
properties of this graph,
Laplacian matrix.
OK.
So let me say L, for Laplacian.
So that matrix-- one
way to describe it
is as A transpose A,
where A is the incidence
matrix of the graph.
Or another way
we'll see is the D--
the degree matrix.
That's diagonal.
And I'll do an example
just to remind you.
Minus the-- well, I don't
know what I'd call this one.
Shall I call it
B for the moment.
And what matrix is B?
That's the adjacency matrix.
Really, you should know
these four matrices.
They're the key four matrices
associated with any graph.
The incidence matrix,
that's m by n--
edges and nodes--
edges and nodes.
So it's rectangular, but I'm
forming A transpose A here.
So I'm forming a symmetric,
positive, semi-definite matrix.
So this Laplacian is symmetric,
positive, semi-definite.
Yeah.
Let me let me just recall
what all these matrices are
for a simple graph.
OK.
So I'll just draw a graph.
All right.
OK.
So the incidence matrix--
there are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 edges--
so five rows.
There are four nodes--
1, 2, 3, and 4.
So four columns.
And a typical row would be edge
1 going from node 1 to node 2,
so it would have a
minus 1 and a 1 there.
And let me take edge 2,
going from 1 to node 3,
so it would have a minus 1
and a 1 there, and so on.
So that's the
incidence matrix A. OK.
What's the degree matrix?
That's simple.
The degree matrix-- well, A
transpose A. This is m by n.
This is n by m.
So it's n by n.
OK.
In this case, 4 by 4.
So the degree matrix
will be 4 by 4, n by n.
And it will tell us the
degree of that, which means--
which we just count the edges.
So three edges going in, node
2, three edges going in, node 3
has just two edges.
And node 4 has just two edges.
So that's the degree matrix.
And then the adjacency
matrix that I've
called B is also 4 by 4.
And what is it?
It tells us which node is
connected to which node.
So I don't allow nodes--
edges that connect a node to
itself, so 0's on the diagonal.
How many-- so which nodes
are connected to node 1?
Well, all of 2 and 4 and
3 are connected to 1.
So I have 1's there.
Node 2-- all three nodes
are connected to node 2.
So I'll have-- the second column
and row will have all three
1's.
How about node 3?
OK.
Only edges-- only two
edges are connected.
Only two nodes are connected
to 3, 1 and 2, but not 4.
So 1 and 2 I have, but not 4.
OK.
So that's the adjacency matrix.
Is that right?
Think so.
This is the degree matrix.
This is the incidence matrix.
And that formula gives
me the Laplacian.
OK.
Let's just write
down the Laplacian.
So if I use the degree minus B--
that's easy.
The degrees were 3, 3, 2, and 2.
Now I have these minuses.
And those were 0.
OK.
So that's a positive,
semi-definite matrix.
Is it a positive
definite matrix?
So let me ask, is it singular
or is it not singular?
Is there a vector
in its null space,
or is there not a vector
in its null space?
Can you solve Dx equals all 0's?
And of course, you can.
Everybody sees that
vector of all 1's will
be a solution to L--
sorry.
I should be saying L here.
Lx equals 0.
Lx equals 0 as for a whole line
of one dimensional null space
of L has dimension 1.
It's got 1 basis
vector, 1, 1, 1, 1.
And that will always happen
with the graph set up
that I've created.
OK.
So that's a first fact, that
this positive, semi-definite
matrix, L, has
lambda 1 equals 0.
And the eigenvector
is constant--
C, C, C, C-- the one
dimensional eigenspace.
Or 1, 1, 1, 1 is the
typical eigenvector.
OK.
Now back to graph clustering.
The idea of graph
clustering is to look
at the Fiedler eigenvector.
This is called the x2--
is the next eigenvector-- is
the eigenvector for the smallest
positive eigenvalue for a
lambda min excluding 0--
so the smallest
eigenvalue of L--
the smallest eigenvalue
and its eigenvector-- this
is called the
Fiedler vector, named
after the Czech mathematician.
A great man in linear algebra,
and he studied this factor--
this situation.
So everybody who knows
about the graph Laplacian
is aware that its
first eigenvalue is 0,
and that the next
eigenvalue is important.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the graph
Laplacian named the Laplacian
because it has connections to--
GILBERT STRANG: To
Laplace's equation, yes.
Yeah, that's a good question.
So why the word--
the name, Laplacian?
So yeah, that's a good question.
So the familiar thing-- so it
connects to Laplace's finite
difference equation, because
we're talking about matrices
here, and not derivatives--
not functions.
So why the word Laplacian?
Well, so if I have a regular--
if my graph is composed of--
so there is a graph with
25 nodes, and 4 times 5--
20, about 40.
This probably has about
40 edges and 25 nodes.
And of course, I
can construct its--
graph all those four
matrices for it--
its incidence matrix,
its degree matrix.
So the degree will be four
at all these inside points.
The degree will be three
at these boundary points.
The degree will be two
at these corner points.
But the-- what will
the matrix L look like?
So what is L?
And that will tell you why
it has this name Laplacian.
So the matrix L will have--
the degree 4 right will
be on the diagonal.
That's coming from
D. The other--
the minus 1's that come from
B, the adjacency matrix,
will be associated with those
nodes, and otherwise, all 0's.
So this is a typical row
of L. This is typical row
of L centered at that node.
So maybe that's node
number 5, 10, 13.
That's 13 out of 25 that
would show you this.
And the-- sorry.
Those are minus 1's.
Minus 1's.
So a 4 on the diagonal,
and four minus 1's.
That's the model problem for
when the graph is a grid--
square grid.
And do you associate that
with Laplace's equation?
So this is the
reason that Laplace--
why Laplace gets in it.
Because Laplace's equation--
the differential equation--
is second derivative with
respect to x squared,
and the second derivative with
respect to y squared is 0.
And what we have
here is Lu equals 0.
It's the discrete Laplacian,
the vector Laplacian,
the graph Laplacian--
where the second x derivative
is replaced by -1, 2, -1.
And the second y derivative
Second differences in the
x and the y directions.
So that's-- yeah.
So that's the
explanation for Laplace.
It's the discrete Laplace--
discrete, or the finite
difference Laplace.
OK.
Now to just finish, I have
to tell you what the--
what clusters-- how do you
decide the clusters from L?
How does L propose two
clusters, the a's and b's?
And here's the answer.
They come from
this eigenvector--
the Fiedler eigenvector.
You look at that eigenvector.
It's got some positive and
some negative components.
The components with positive
numbers of this eigenvector--
so the positive
components of x--
of-- this eigenvector.
And there are negative
components of this eigenvector.
And those are the two clusters.
So it's-- the cluster is--
the two clusters are decided
by the eigenvector--
by the signs-- plus or minus
signs of the components.
The plus signs go in one and
the minus signs go in another.
And you have to experiment to
see that that would succeed.
I don't know what it would do on
this, actually, because that's
hardly split up into two.
I suppose maybe the
split is along a line
like that or something, to get--
I don't know what clustering.
This is not a graph that
is naturally clustered,
but you could still
do k-means on it.
You could still do
spectral clustering.
And you would find
this eigenvector.
Now what's the point
about this eigenvector?
I'll finish in one moment.
What do we know about
that eigenvector as
compared to that one?
So here was an
eigenvector all 1's.
Let me just make it
all 1's, 1, 1, 1, 1.
In that picture, it's 25 1's.
Here's the next eigenvector up.
And what's the relation between
those two eigenvectors of L?
They are--
AUDIENCE: Orthogonal.
GILBERT STRANG: Orthogonal.
These are eigenvectors
of a symmetric matrix.
So they're orthogonal.
So that means-- to be
orthogonal to this guy means
that your components
add to 0, right?
A Vector.
Is orthogonal to all 1's.
That dot product is just,
add up the components.
So we have a bunch of
positive components
and a bunch of
negative components.
They have the same sum, because
the dot product with that is 0.
And those two components--
those two sets of components are
your--
to tell you the two clusters
in spectral clustering.
So it's a pretty
nifty algorithm.
It does ask you to
compute an eigenvector.
And that, of course, takes time.
And then there's a third,
more direct algorithm
to do this optimization problem.
Well, actually, there are many.
This is an important
problem, so there
are many proposed algorithms.
Good.
OK.
I'm closing up.
Final question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
do more than two clusters?
GILBERT STRANG: Well,
certainly for k-means.
Now, if I had to do three
clusters with Fiedler,
I would look at the
first three eigenvectors.
And, well, the first
one would be nothing.
And I would look
at the next two.
And that would be
pretty successful.
If I wanted six
clusters, it probably
would fall off in the
quality of the clustering.
Yeah.
But that certainly-- I
would look at the lowest six
eigenvectors, and get somewhere.
Yeah.
Right.
So OK.
So that's a topic--
an important topic-- a sort of
standard topic in applied graph
theory.
OK.
So see you Wednesday.
I'm hoping, on Wednesday--
so Professor Edelman has
told me a new and optimal way
to look at the problem
of backpropagation.
Do you remember backpropagation?
If you remember
the lecture on it--
you don't want to remember
the lecture on it.
It's a tricky, messy
thing to explain.
But he says, if I explain it
using Julia in linear algebra,
it's clear.
So we'll give him a
chance on Wednesday
to show that revolutionary
approach to the explanation
of backpropagation.
And I hope for--
I told him he could
have half an hour,
and projects would
take some time.
I hope-- now we've had
two with wild applause.
So I hope we get a couple
more in our last class.
OK.
See you Wednesday.
And if you bring--
well, if you have projects
ready, send them to me online,
and maybe a print out as well.
That would be terrific.
If you don't have them ready
by the hour, they can go--
the envelope outside my
office would receive them.
Good.
So I'll see you Wednesday
for the final class.